have you ever wondered how zeus became  king of the gods how poseidon hades and  zeus decided who would rule over which  domain something that important must  have been decided by hand-to-hand combat  where zeus overpowered his brothers and  no  okay well zeus did save his siblings  from an eternity inside their father's  stomach and therefore they no then it  must have been because zeus defeated  typhon the father of all monsters when  all of the other gods ran away no i mean  zeus did have about a thousand affairs  so maybe he had the most heirs to the  throne that is true but no they simply  drew lots or straws hades was given the  underworld poseidon the ocean and zeus  the sky with the sky being above all  zeus was crowned the king some may say  that zeus had earned the right to be  king and others would argue that he had  rigged the entire process to begin with  either way zeus did love to cheat in  every way possible